so I've just got a tweet here this is  from Penny Morden it looks like penny  mordant has dropped out of the race  I am proud of the campaign we ran and  grateful to all of those across all  sides of our party who gave me their  backing we owe it to the country to each  other and to Rishi to unite and work  together for the good of the nation  there is much work to be done so there  you have it breaking news Penny mordant  just ahead of the announcement has  pulled out of the race she obviously did  not hit the numbers Rishi sunak is the  new prime minister Rishi sunak is the  new prime minister he won the majority  of the Parliamentary support after  losing the race so bitterly back in July